USB-C was supposed to save us from the every-device-uses-a-different-cable
problem.
What went wrong?
I love USB-C connectors.
I love the symmetry.
I love how they look.
And yes, tons of phones and laptops have moved
to using USB-C...with one notable exception.
This is really exciting.
One cable that fits everything!
Until you realize that all of these cables
look the same, but are not the same!
Some will charge your device, but not transfer
any data.
Others will charge your smaller device, but
not your larger device.
Some work as monitor cables, others don't.
Some can transfer up to 40 gigabits per second.
Others can only do 5 gigabits per second,
which is a huge difference if you're actually
trying to move large video files.
*deep breath* Okay.
On top of that, some companies have added
their own proprietary tech into these USB-C
cables.
Apple looooves that proprietary tech.
Even as a bona fide nerd gearhead, I still
find myself deeply frustrated by this.
I mean, just look at this ridiculous chart!
Ugh!
So, maybe going from this to this wasn't all
that it was cracked up to be.